welcome to this video playing from zinan
out of your mind is the translation of
this german name to 220 let's see ya
this I played played him right off quite
often and it's very year yeah that's a
very right range of playing fifth
playing styles coming from this this
person once in a while he plays a really
like a complete madman and then Jen then
very decently okay I went for a modern
benoni very quick edge for heaven yeah
he went for them the night the night to
a system introduced I think by I didn't
saw it right this was introduced by
names of which John Bishop g5 was a
tricky move I don't really want to play
King edge so Jim
hard to not play it I mean age five
looks really low really ugly okay but
now something like III Bishop d3 and age
five is a bit of a nuisance
he just writes me Merry Christmas okay I
reply wishing the same it's a bit a bit
early for Christmas wishes at least at
the recording time I think if i'm not
mistaken this video will be live on
youtube during christmas days but i'm
recording it a few days before that okay
a form mmhmm if I hadn't played a
sixsome not clear if you need to do that
okay I need to untangle pieces so I
don't like to exchange this Bishop but I
need to relieve some pressure here so I
go if I manage to play Knight f6 and
some some strengthening moves gathers
look son quite decent interesting where
is it going to our form I can take g5
okay 95 maybe looking for very strange
position
okay come on let's open the queenside he
hasn't cashed lot and this might might
help me if he takes be 5 i'm going to
look piayed at the end opening up and
then threatening before
hmm it looks quite quite decent for
black mmm okay let's let's check it in
more detail night be five maybe the
instant rugby 80 I just take they are
probably taking a group pietas better as
some b2 is immediately on the fire and
if he takes with the bishop now I can
take play rugby eight and at least have
pressure on the bee farm and that's not
the only idea yeah this talking top took
him a bit by a surprise it seems yeah
but what about the champ I think you
really should take with the bishop I
don't really see her what else to do
taking enormous time Ian
he's still online it's not 94 this I
didn't expect I mean it was a almost
clear that there was some some
unexpected move coming prove interesting
okay if I just take it i mean 95 95
looks looks like looks tricky by taking
rook takes Queen d5 touching c4 yeah
this is this is the easiest way to play
wait wait beefy mMmmm very tricky
position Queen takes some PS Move slide
rookie 7 threatening bishop g6
hmm ok but maybe I should take any way a
rupee 7f nap this is doesn't make much
sense rookie seven Bishop Bishop c6 I
can play okay come on let's do that I'm
spending far too much time for moves
like that yeah Queen h5 now this is a
substantial threat I Bishop before I
didn't think about that move at all hmm
okay i need to give the Queen it seems
which isn't totally clear check now I'm
not not very well coordinated probably
something like g4s very good didn't play
that
you know I thought g4 was very strong
no Bishop to e6 this looks like quite a
sturdy construction 27 oz may be good I
don't know not the same came if i manage
d4 and in exchange it's okay time
morning check check
going to the beach upon
check check check check check white
forfeits on time oh yeah well winning
was really a bit bit insane and she just
went into the skin King g5 stuff yeah
right some be lucky that's true yeah
King g5 was a was unnecessary of course
yeah very this about here it's probably
lost i mean my my piece coordination is
not not good enough it was just them
just unnecessary to to give away the
queen of course yeah I can I can take I
can take em I overlap that right here
that this is not check not a problem the
queen is on g2 protecting g6 I only saw
queen age 5 26 and this just as wins
outright look here Bishop f3 and wide
resins basically zombies down like all
pawns yeah it's a it's a very tricky
kind of game in the bin only sometimes
German at the end I was very lucky that
he ran to King g5 yeah I hope you liked
it please some roller coaster type of
game thanks for watching